una visión muy clara se diría para la
recuperación de la economía muy enfocada
en cómo recuperarla en medio de esta
crisis económica como promover la
inversión extranjera e insistió en ese
principio ideológico del partido
conservador y es en el recorte de
impuestos Pese a que su paquete
financiero ha causado todo tipo de
crisis en los últimos días lo resumió de
la siguiente manera crecimiento
crecimiento y crecimiento tratando de
dar tranquilidad a los mercados que han
estado en crisis justamente por ese
paquete financiero lista dijo que el
gobierno el ministro de finanzas cuasi
cuarta en va a seguir trabajando muy de
cerca con el banco de Inglaterra y dejó
claro entonces que el ministro no se irá
que ha sido una de las solicitudes que
se ha hecho en los últimos días que el
ministro por esta crisis en que la libra
esterlina cayó a sus niveles
récord debía irse pero hoy ratificó que
no la primera ministra también dijo que
el seguirá dando apoyo económico y de
entrenamiento a las tropas ucranianas
por el tiempo que sea necesario y dijo
que está segura que Ucrania resultará
vencedora en esta guerra frente a Rusia
como lo mencionabas dos manifestantes de
greenpeace irrumpieron en el auditorio e
interrumpieron el discurso del disfraz
por un par de minutos Tenían un cartel
amarillo que decía quién votó por esto
por supuesto fueron removidas casi que
inmediatamente por la seguridad de este
auditorio listadas en este primer
discurso trata de
convencer a su público a sus electores
los que votaron por ella de que
efectivamente Tiene un plan económico
para salvar al país en esta crisis pero
ahora que es primera ministra debe
convencer a todo el país debe convencer
a todos los británicos de que
efectivamente lo tiene